I'm looking forward to getting a
makeover I'm so serious I will literally
wear and most let's say anything on that
rack but there and I looked after the
selection of our prom court we flew them
all out to Los Angeles the first thing
we do is give them a tour of busty
motion picture studios everybody right
now did we all get the memo to wear
black and blue today black and blue
sounds a little sad melancholy right
we're gonna take you from black and blue
to rainbow so to help you on your
wardrobe styling journey I'm gonna
introduce a friend of mine Roman Sipe
who is a fashion designer and stylist
are you all ready to try on some
fabulous from wardrobe well you know
what this means
oh gosh no no once more with feeling
I want to feel like a hardcore lesbian
but like I like hardcore belly I want to
be like this is me I want them to look
at me and say she's a homosexual
expression in the queer community
through one's wardrobe and one styling
is a huge part of our identity I'll
probably go with a jumpsuit because I
feel Kapus makes it a little bit more
fierce I am ready for this statement
full jacket and then I wanted some nice
brown loafers shoes elegant modern and
dramatic that is my style the dress with
like weird cutout pieces maybe some
geometric shapes something totally weird
and unique and cool I just want to be
snatched otter and Rowan we have another
special trip for you we will bring you
to our good friends over sharp suiting
to get something custom fitted there are
a lot of people out there who are
struggling with the fact that the
clothes they've been given since they
were born might not represent who they
are
Liane fitted Rowan and I he was amazing
I didn't know that he was trans I
thought he was just like all your
guesses dude like it's cool they started
talking about binders and tea and I was
like oh [ __ ] so great oh my gosh you are
so handsome
I like the funky collar finding like
something that actually fits me and my
body type is very hard because they
don't exactly make suits that are
tailored towards more feminine-looking
people I felt so proud I've never got
fitted by a trans person for anything
now I know why the suit fits me so well
welcome prom court to rob our Beauty
here in West Hollywood the gay capital
of Southern California we've assembled
essentially a superhero Beauty team and
leader of it right now is my very good
friend David dang who's a celebrity hair
stylist thank you so much you guys for
being here we were
touched by your stories and not only
that but we were touched because we
support the community in every type of
way y'all know what this means
hey right gets a Dumber every time
[Music]
are you nervous I excited okay good well
I love that you're fabulous
I would love to deepen your tone
just a bit nothing too over the top and
just like off the side but you ready I'm
so ready highlighter for the God really
dramatic eye shadow because I can't do
that but like if someone else to do it
Saamy up
[Music]
it's like the ice cream shop got hair
seriously plenty falls like hurled you
ready to go we want to keep this a
little bit of surprise but for some of
the prom court supporters like the
parents and the friends we will have
some makeup and hair for y'all as well
the team is here to support that girl
boy yes I like it good that's really
good
I like Csonka whoo you got a style all
right so I hope you enjoyed a little bit
of that pampering don't feel good
y'all looking good I need you to go
because we're meet later at the house
you can see all of your children and
your friends final looks what are you
doing why you still standing here get
out of here
get out of here why you keep buy off
soon damn it looks sink amazing I've
never had my hair this tall before it
looks really good
white girl can cut it yeah how does it
feel to know how hot you are hurting me
that maybe 3 2 1 your hair
Oh Oh I think I'll just go with the hair
it's better than I thought
like yes I do like a lot thank you so
handsome check it out this is so fun
what's happening to me I'm going to LA
and I'm getting everything changed I'm
gonna go back and it was like what
happened I love it thank you so much oh
my god have an amazing time tonight
three two one
whoo [ __ ] [ __ ] give me gummy pass
David got me that thank you so much
thank you so much only diet for real and
like I've never ever said this about
myself but like I can honestly say for
like the first time in my life like I
actually feel beautiful all right let's
not get emotional everybody I need to
drop it low in two seconds so
everybody's here you all look gorgeous
thank you lead are you excited to see
otter how you feeling I'm excited for
them I'm like what does they look like
they better like kill it
they better walk in here like a runway
model
[Applause]
McGary
oh my god I've never seen you this bad
but I know I don't think I've ever felt
this masculine in my entire life have
you seen him in a suit no are you
excited yes I'm very excited this is
really important to Christopher and I'm
just happy to be a part of it so I'm
really excited to see him where's Chris
I'm Lucy prince lair
oh yeah I feel like we're matching kind
of you are yeah look so good I mean you
came in and you already slayed so it's
nice to just live elevate you to the
heavens
your tiny baby caterpillar is now a
beautiful butterfly on her way to prom
how pumped are you real excited stages
worn all different kinds of outfits shed
all different hair colors so normal to
me but excited to see her for this
exciting for her
oh yes sadden excited what you said
because this is my little girl getting
big get them doing it you say JC
Caitlin's I'm ready are excited are you
really excited yeah Don we're ready I'm
ready
oh my god she looks really good
hey I love this this is what you want it
oh hey
power couple look at those mad I love
that I'm excited you guys are runway
ready Rowan has no emotion so I would
like to see like real person under right
under my kid how are you feeling I'm
mixed emotions I'm nervous I'm excited
you are the only one like in a suit like
not sure people were cool and now
there's like you're not the like odwin
anymore everyone true equally very odd
equally odd equally queer equally queer
it's not like I'm just going to prom to
go to promise I'm going to prom to go to
prom to be actually me at prom and not
to be something that my school wants me
to be you guys ready for the grand
finale
yes how are you feeling up I'm so
excited that I might actually myself
oh my god
I feel beautiful and honestly I can say
that's the first time I've ever
genuinely felt that like I know that I
may come off as like cocky or confident
but that all comes from a place of
faking it I really feel like having gone
through this experience definitely
boosted my confidence and made me feel
more like me you look so beautiful
you're just so amazing as much as it's
your dream it's my dream too I've
watched you through this whole thing and
how you look good I think there was like
a disconnection between appearance and
like personality just seeing her being
completely herself and feeling beautiful
is really incredible because I know she
does not have a lot of self-confidence
often but I could tell you felt
beautiful I feel like I'm ready to have
a really fun night and I don't never
forget
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm excited to wear like exactly what I
want feel really confident and to be
feeling really confident like next to
Caitlin and knowing that she's feeling
good and that we can like do anything
yeah this Quinn that you're gonna see up
the problem is definitely the Quinn that
I wanted to express fierce fabulous a
queen a badass [ __ ] and she does not
take no for an answer
I'm with people that I've barely met yet
I felt so comfortable with them so it
was nice to like share the experience
with them and be able to be a part of it
[Music]
now that our prom court has revealed
their gorgeous stunning and sickening
prom looks they're gonna jump into a
limo and head over to BuzzFeed Squier
problem how's it feel being in the limo
well it's pretty great
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]